It's one thing to animate characters by hand, however there's a huge variety of
phenomena that are governed by the laws of physics. For simple tasks such as
bouncing ball, keyframing can suffice. Here's a keyframing timeline in 3D
Studio Max, and the process of setting up an animation like this. What if we
wanted to have the bouncing ball keep bouncing? Keyframing by hand becomes a
challenge since there's no simple repetition. For these phenomena we turn to
simulation to generate the animations. Here's another example. A set of bodies
attracted to each other by gravitational forces. For the bouncing ball, we
could have perhaps written a little program that would create the key frames
for us. Here the motions are complex and are calculated frame to frame on the
fly. Many other phenomena can be simulated in real time. Here's an example of a
spring system. These three demos were all created in GlowScript, a system
that's even higher level than Three.js. Simulating friction is a scenario that
can be challenging, but critical if you want to get anywhere. A blowing wind
has drag and lift constraints, cloth has stretch constraints. This is a
relatively simple system that can be solved in real time as you can see.
Simulations can be affected by the user's actions. As a simple example, in this
demo, you can turn the wind on and off, add a ball, and so on. These are not
pre-stored canned animations, but are interactive.